[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
give me
one minute and i'll show you how google
cloud operation suite can help you
monitor
and troubleshoot your infrastructure and
applications
the tools in the suite provide deep
insights and best practices that help
your team's developer
operations devops and sres utilize
google sre principles
it captures signals monitors systems and
services
and helps troubleshoot issues with
built-in telemetry for google services
out-of-box dashboards define and manage
alerts recommendations
and more the tools include monitoring
logging and advanced
observabilities such as trace debugger
and profiler
cloud logging aggregates log data at
scale from all your infrastructure and
applications into a single location
this enables users to search and analyze
large volumes of blog to troubleshoot
problems quickly
and gives you full control to decide how
and where to store the logs
cloud monitoring provides visibility of
health across your absent infrastructure
regardless of where it is you can even
define custom metrics unique to your use
case
and send them to external systems using
metrics explorer and monitoring query
language you can analyze these metrics
and can even set alerts and slos
advanced observability feature trace
provides insight into request flow
service topology and latency issues in
your app
debugger allows you to inspect running
applications after deployment without
needing to stop
or slow down and profiler continually
analyzes your code's performance on each
service
so you can improve its speed and reduce
your cost
while trace tracks relationships and
latency between services
profiler tracks this across individual
functions and your code base and
debugger
helps find the root cause you can use
the cloud console
or the api to use cloud operation tools
all cloud capabilities offer a very
generous free tier to make it easy for
you to get started
so next time you're looking for an
observability solution take a minute to
look at
cloud operations to learn more check out
cloud.google.com
products operations